failed former president Donald Trump
once arrested twice impeached has been
indicted a second time this time
federally he will be arrested and booked
on Tuesday in Miami at 3 P.M Eastern
Time ladies and gentlemen it is
happening and it is even more
unprecedented if you can if you can even
say such a such a thing
um wow what a day what a night CNBC
report
ex-president's arraignment comes day
before his birthday Donald Trump has
become the first U.S president former or
otherwise to be indicted on federal
criminal charges Trump announced in
Thursday night posts on his truth social
platform that prosecutors notified his
attorneys he had been indicted NBC News
confirmed soon after that
he faces seven charges